baden-württembergs ministerpräsident
winfried kretschmann hat sich für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht im kampf gegen
das corona virus ausgesprochen in einem
gastbeitrag für die frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung schrieb der grünen
politiker gemeinsam mit bayerns
regierungschef markus söder eine
impfpflicht ist kein verstoß gegen die
freiheitsrechte vielmehr ist sie die
voraussetzung dafür dass wir unsere
freiheit zurückgewinnen bei uns im
studio ist bildpolitik chef jan schäfer
fliegender wechsel hier immer bei uns im
studio da wo carli underberg gerade noch
stand jan also ist das sozusagen der
durchbruch für die impfpflicht
es handelt sich hier um den
ministerpräsidenten von baden
württemberg also noch mal es ist nicht
der durchbruch denn es handelt sich um
den ministerpräsidenten von baden
württemberg den einzigen denen die
grünen haben aber natürlich ist er
einige wichtige stimme wir wissen dass
es beispielsweise auf seiten der fdp
ganz ganz viel widerstand gegen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht gibt auch olaf
scholz hat sich in letzter zeit immer
noch sehr zurückhaltend geäußert wir
wissen aber auch beispielsweise von
robert habeck der schon im letzten jahr
gesagt hat wenn sich nicht genügend
menschen freiwillig impfen lassen würden
dann müsse es halt eine allgemeine
impfpflicht gegen geben in dieses horn
stößt nun auch winfried kretschmann wir
wissen auch von heute vormittag das der
csu vorstand um markus söder ja gesagt
hat es müsse in deutschland eine
allgemeine impfpflicht geben also die
debatte ist in vollem gange aber die
ampel parteien die sind da noch sehr
sehr unterschiedlicher meinung geimpft
genesen oder gestorben wir sehen es hier
hinter uns der ausbruch von jens spahn
heute morgen er hat selbst dazu gesagt
das mag zynisch klingen wolltest auf die
spitze treiben im moment wenn ich
richtig informiert bin
tagen die gesundheitsminister der länder
dauert die konferenz noch an es gibt
eine beschlussvorlage du hast schon mal
reingeschaut genau wir wissen eigentlich
die beschlussvorlage ist jetzt auch
einen beschluss die im 16
gesundheitsminister der bundesländer
die haben getagt und wir sehen hier
unter anderem ein ergebnis dieses
gipfels dieses regelmäßig tagenden
gremiums dass man einmal darauf einen
das bundesministerium für gesundheit
wird aufgefordert alles zu tun um die
impfungen mit dem impfstoff von biontech
pfizer weiterhin in vollem umfang zu
ermöglichen den impfstoff von beyoncé
kaiser im rahmen der regelversorgung und
vorzüglich bereitzustellen sowie die
vorhandenen lagerbestände so weit wie
möglich rasch auszuliefern nach unseren
informationen ist dieser beschluss auch
am ende mit 16 zu null stimmen durch
gegangen das heißt da gab es jetzt schon
eine deutliche watsch'n auch für jens
spahn der ja eine rationierung von
biontech impfstoff für die nächsten
wochen verfügt hat gesagt es ist einfach
nicht genug da wie kann man so eine
aufforderung machen wenn es tatsächlich
praktische probleme gibt es gibt die
aufforderung der 16 gesundheitsminister
der länder dass hier entspannen alles
tun muss um die verfügbare menge an
biontech impfstoff deutlich zu erhöhen
also er soll nicht nur mit dem
unternehmen selbst sprechen er soll auch
versuchen über die europäische ebene
noch an zusätzlichen impfstoff
heranzukommen das ist der auftrag der
formuliert worden wurde und 16
gesundheitsminister der länder die
heißen ist auch nicht gut dass sie
entspannen hier entsprechend vorgesorgt
hat ja wir wollen nochmal einmal
reinhören in das was ich entspanne mich
heute morgen gesagt hat da ging es ja
eben genau um diese impfung und wie es
über den winter heraus aussehen könnte
was zum zweiten bleibt ist ein umstand
den wir schon seit monaten beschreiben
wahrscheinlich wird am ende dieses
winters
so ziemlich jeder in deutschland
das bild wurde manchmal schon etwas
zynisch genannt geimpft gewesen oder
gestorben sein
ja wir haben es ja gerade schon sagt
geimpft gewesen oder gestorben das sind
schon harte worte muss es denn jetzt
auch solche harten worte geben dass es
jetzt eben weiter geht und der
bekämpfung der korona krise wir hören
das ja immer wieder diese vergleiche wir
erinnern uns an markus söder der auch
mal sagt die hier jeden tag stürzt in
deutschland ein flugzeug voll besetzt ab
und wollte damit auch auf die
todeszahlen hinweisen jetzt also so ein
satz von jens sparen das sind immer
wieder diese vergleiche die politiker
ziehen einerseits um angst zu machen
offenbar aber um gleichzeitig auch von
politischem versagen abzulenken denn es
ist ja interessant dass eigentlich diese
impfkampagne schon vor monaten ins
stocken geraten ist und jens spahn eines
so gut wie gar nichts unternommen hat um
diese impfkampagne neues leben
einzuhauchen jetzt stellen wir fest
plötzlich steigen die zahlen derjenigen
die sich impfen lassen wollen und
angeblich ist plötzlich gar nicht genug
impfstoff da also da passt ja einiges
nicht zusammen und dann zu sagen ja
entweder seite am ende dieses winters
nämlich eine märz oder april alle
geimpft oder sind alle chinesen oder die
die nicht geniess umkämpften sind alle
tot das ist ja ein versagens
eingeständnis für die eigene politik
schäfer danke für die anordnung
gerne